hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again
today we're gonna be talking about the
stuff that happen on the dead stream
today nothing crazy happened of course
it is the is the first week after the
initial release of the new character
Sean who zan who whatever you want to
call my just call him soon doc cause
it's easier so that's basically it
there's really not gonna be much I will
be explaining that throughout this video
though so as always let's get started so
first up there's gonna be a rank two
Vanquisher challenge be the faction with
the most ranked matches one and you guys
are gonna be getting some rewards as
usual of course you have to participate
all that good stuff you know the plan on
top of that there's going to be an emote
sale all kill card emotes are not going
to be 4000 steal as opposed to 7000 if
you don't remember there's an emote that
all the characters have I don't really
think all the new characters have it I
believe definitely the original cast and
I believe the year one and the move in
have it except soon da basically the
kill card and throw it down has your
emblem pop up that's gonna be 4,000
steel instead of 7,000 so definitely
save your money for that [ __ ] and also
I'm I don't know if this is entirely
true cuz this was actually not showed in
the roadmap but it was showed on a on a
reddit post basically there is going to
be a sale on like the 29th of November
because of it being very coast if not
the same day that Black Friday is so it
has to do with like masks and executions
so I'm not entirely sure if this is 100%
true because once again this was not
shown on the roadmap so take that with a
grain of salt
but if you do want to buy an execution I
would maybe suggest waiting at least
another couple weeks just in case this
thing actually is true and if it happens
to not be true I do apologize I have no
idea if it is or not and then the last
two bits of information is that the John
who or soon dot is now alive on all
platforms of course for everybody that
has for any character doesn't matter
fish season past or not so the people
that had the season past that was live
last week as you saw I was streaming out
basically every day if not you should
definitely come by the streams but if
you do not have the season passed he's
going to be available right now for
15,000 steal so definitely go pick him
up he's an absolutely amazing character
I think he in terms of a competitive
standpoint I give him a low be a high C
tier he's not terrible but he's also not
great either but I find him a lot of fun
in the customizations really cool as
you've seen and of course if you want to
see I need two emotes executions
the customization side of the character
I've made early access videos weeks ago
and honestly I'm loving the character
I'm already wrapped ending with him I
cannot wait to go back and play him
again the next thing I also released is
the beta mode for spectator mode so we
talked about spectator mode has been
going along you know it's been being
talked about for multiple weeks months
you know it's been a really hyped up and
I'm actually super excited to finally
get to go into game today so it is
available on all platforms on any system
doesn't matter doesn't matter what
timezone doesn't matter what platform
you're on Xbox Playstation PC North
America European doesn't matter
everybody can hop in right now in game
and check it all you have to do is go to
any of your friends that are on playing
the game and then go over to their name
and you can click spectate sadly if
you're like me and don't have too many
friends that actually played this game
it might not be as useful for you but
it's still cool nonetheless for those
other people that need to and of course
from a tournament perspective and
competitive scene it's gonna be really
sick as well hey guys that's gonna be
the end of the beta casts hopefully guys
did enjoy if you're a seasoned past
player and you've been playing sundal
let me know your opinion on the
character also let me know your rep if
you've been grinding a lot like me also
and if you're a new player and you've
actually just happened to play the
character for the past couple hours or
so let me know how you're experiencing
the new character like I said I think
he's a bit weak so maybe a few buffs
might help him because I think he's not
that great but he's also not too
terrible either but I guys like the V
for doing Josh subscribe if you're new
and take care guys enjoy the rest today
peace out they give Ross in the video